e gli altri ragazzi mi sono video sono
fa vj e ritmi e compagni di avventura
fra vi lasciamo l'episodio di the forest
rischio della protesta ma vediamo cos'è
lo sa dato una fune uno swatch
no mi hai [ __ ] rolex dispiace ho
trovato rolex che lo figo altro che in
anni nelle miniere quasi trovano già i
rolex lo snack ho trovato una felpa ron
howard si faccia motivo però giuro hard
guarda c'è l'altra parte dell'aereo dove
l'aveva in cui ma fin qua non ne ho idea
ho trovato altra parte l'aereo ma non è
fisicamente ace la pistola
c'è la pistola te la lascio prendila del
giorno magari cento tra i player poi ci
sono due zii ma io li lascerei dormire
un vero disturba di cina ma non insomma
lo sai che se non salviamo la partita e
moriamo perdiamo tutto allora proprio
oggi ai proventi giocatori di rugby come
se avessi la palla che porta alla
vittoria esami a muro aria
prendi chi cazzo è attento a quella
dell'altra usain bolt lei praise not
impresse l'attenzione fuoco attenzione a
fuoco a testa una sua corsa mai pensato
ok ecco casa nostra casa nostra
mamma mia io li abbiamo fatto sembravamo
i black bloc cattivissimi credibile non
so come abbiamo fatto in da house to
save che io ho solo questo effige
l'altra è scomparsa
ci sembrava vede rientra poi ci pensiamo
andiamo al forno e dormiamo prima
dormiamo con la addio l'ansia di vive ed
è anche il nuovo giorno nella casa ci
siamo partiti malissimo di primo
episodio tra virgolette adesso invece
abbiamo la situazione sotto controllo
potremmo qualche lamento per un po di
direi di sì però sai cosa devi rifare
anche ciò che fare il fuoco quello bello
grosso o con bello grosso sorgente
grossi da alcune allora piccolo effige
piccolina
ci vogliono dei tronchi e per tirar su
questa roba è veramente grossissimo c'è
un cazzo di coccodrillo dentro la nostra
casa ma cosa stai dicendo
c'è un [ __ ] coccodrillo porca [ __ ]
non si fa veramente lo dove gli hai
fatto cadere la pro addosso attenzione
che me ne vado veloce forse aveva quasi
dentro ai a noi avere sbagliato vita in
un attacco quando lo zio ci siamo morti
per quella nuova moria brun coccodrillo
ma [ __ ] dove la tecnica di snack
scrutiamo non si fa niente non si fa
niente se cazzata in carriera dietro
visto quali da tempo c'è chi può
trasformare l'aspetto la macchina è
cascato l'allenatore lo prevedano un
sacco a pelo
assolutamente sì mi chiamano abbiamo
scartato bene i testi bag assi possiamo
poco indossarlo come corazza guardavi
chiare cioè lei i polsini magnificat a
novoli farlo anch'io zio michele abbiamo
anche l'arma lo messi anch'io che
figurava bellissimo ma poi ci sono altri
tre noteremo che la cucina dall'europa
in realtà è finito il bonfire quasi ok
ho finito il bonfire aspettando fuoco
che questo un momento epico
io ho fatto il fuoco ciao bello lo zio
ben sai
tutta roba fresca presa da me sto
mettendo le recinto tutto questo sempre
domani perplesso di una cosa rosa la
porta ma perché ti fai domande che non
dovresti fa conosciamo l'attenzione che
arrivano due bambinata parte una bambina
preso fuoco
il bellissimo end quando arrivano le
lepri e si cucinano da sole la testa di
cervo che lo serve la testa del cervo
perché non si cucina sarda faceva cosa
questo perché ama champ lo racconta è
bella la mia figlia non os x non ci ho
messo un cazzo a farlo solo annunciato
un corpo la gabbia per conigli ci serve
sempre piaceva pure il biglietto il
cammello non mi hai fregato stavolta
bastardo che ighalo importante cosa che
mi ha colpito è lo zio mi ha colpito
qualcosa è stato colpito
c'è un coccodrillo norme dietro di te
come fai a non sapere
padana l'abbiamo ucciso io scuola lo
vivo ho capito ma non è attaccato il web
è detto non capisco che cosa ti giri un
coccodrillo gigante fantastico e larry
meravigliosa maghetti è così i fan sono
pazzo ma con un colpo è volato via f il
cinese
e io riuscissi a fare il corso per
raccogliere i tronchi maledizione ogni
volta che non dobbiamo farci 200 giri ma
in un giro sono le prendiamo un botto e
questo in teoria porca eva merda
chocobar cherillo valles i coccodrilli
due tavoli
ho creato la slitta guarda quanto sono
bravo e bello bellissimo
[Risate]
[Musica]
come abbiamo fatto basta ma capita no
che tattica o per lanciarti oltre il
filo di legno al tar a bari 36 babbo
natale g 80 di quella che siamo messi da
dio allora facciamo così anni o un
tirato giù perché questo giu madre
russia che non avrà addosso attento
apache is naples bellissimo abbiamo
rifatto anche l'intera ma va bene forse
vuole un capito è troppo divertente sto
gioco cioè ormai ma puoi chiudere la
porta a noah z acids io li ho messi io
oddio sta evocando il demonio demonio ma
bruciore di stomaco
ho finito la gabbia per per conigli
vediamo se funziona ed a funzionare tra
palestra sto [ __ ] tipo disegno così
almeno capiscono no tu devi in denaro è
già dentro qua qua dentro che è così io
ti prendo e ti uccido e chi mangiava
bene grazie allora ragazzi con questa
leprotto che tenta di salire la montagna
in modo molto triste adesso che abbiamo
completato un pochettino la casa che
siamo messi parecchio bene direi abbiamo
anche coperto quasi interamente una
parte poi manca l'altra sopra non c'è
non è quasi necessario per in teoria non
scende nessuno però la lasciamo per
ultima per come costruiremo veloce è la
muraglia cinese questa adesso siamo
pronti per andare alla voragine quindi
abbiamo anche le corde per andar giù ma
chi è android ci sei
voglio andare andiamo andiamo alla bat
caverna per ora dobbiamo far conto come
arrivavamo prima prima arrivavamo da
questa parte quindi se noi andiamo di
qua vieni il posto se è vero
qua quando vedo nieri dovrebbe essere
qua allora il tiro sul lago dall'altra
parte era bella grossa e quindi ok
dovremmo essere dovremmo in teoria
esserci davanti forse questa eccola
provando trovata l'ho trovata di madonna
roberto gradi la bravo sasha è allora io
proporrei di fare una cosa prima di
entrare qua dentro
sempre se possiamo entrare la cosa che
propongo di fare è prendere un
che correva come sparta di calcio nel
coso che palle
è bravo bravo a un filo ok test destra
sparta test spacca presa buttato giù la
testa è sporta
ma cosa sta incollato ma com'è possibile
mara fango ecco è caduto è venuto no no
eccolo cadere tu non cadere tu ecco la
mandava si è pensato
vabbè ma secondo me guarda se ti butti
da quei centri il buco sono 100 punti e
sono anche 100 morti o c'è un piccione
che si è posato sui piedi dei canali va
bene allora facciamo così che in riga o
inside caverna ok cose se ci schiantiamo
possiamo tornare indietro
l'accordo ragazzi siamo arrivati davanti
alla voragine enorme nella prossima
puntata la scaleremo al contrario non
abbiamo neanche la più pallida di che
cosa ci sia dentro ma ecco in un secondo
ci siamo trovati abbiamo costruito un
mezzo villaggio che hanno ucciso un boss
abbiamo fatto miliardi di cose 100 mila
mi piace per continuare questa serie di
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto cosa
mi piace al momento è un mi piace a
capace di facebook come sottoscrizioni
sono rischiate riuscì vediamo il
prossimo video verrà negato